[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDREW LEWIS: Hi, everyone.
Thank you very much
for coming along.
I'm Andrew.
I'm a Software Engineer
on the ExoPlayer team.
MARC BACHINGER: And I'm Marc.
I'm Developer Advocate
for Android Media.
ANDREW LEWIS: So
in today's session,
we're hoping to demonstrate
how you can build really,
really fully-featured media
playback functionality
into apps using quite
little code using ExoPlayer.
And to do that, we're
going to guide you
through the process of
building two applications.
We're going to start by
focusing on the video use case.
We're going to build a
simple video player app that
will play an MP4 stream.
Then we're going to show
you how to insert ads
alongside that video content.
Then we're going to
shift our focus to audio.
We're going to show
you how to play audio
in a background service.
We're going to show
you how to integrate
with Android MediaSessions.
And finally, we're
going to take a look
at some new functionality
we've recently
released for downloading
media for offline playback.
So like last year,
we're hoping to have
a mixture of some
introductory content
and also some coverage of
slightly more tricky use cases,
so hopefully there's
something for everyone.
And with that in mind,
I'm going to start
by saying a bit about what
ExoPlayer is for anyone who
hasn't used the library before.
OK.
Clicker doesn't
seem to be working.
Next slide.
Great.
So ExoPlayer is an
application-level media player.
That means that you choose
which version of ExoPlayer
you'd like to use, and
then you bundle the player
implementation into your
application as a dependency,
and what that gives
you is consistent
playback functionality across
all different Android versions
and across all
different devices.
ExoPlayer works from API 16--
that's Android
Jelly Bean upwards,
so with that you can reach more
than 99% of active devices.
The project is open source,
is hosted on GitHub,
and we have an active
community there,
and you can file issues
with feature requests, bugs,
and you can even send
us pull requests.
ExoPlayer is also
quite widely used
both within Google Applications
like the YouTube app
for Android, and also
in Google Play Movies.
It's also quite widely used in
the wider Android community.
And there are actually
over 200,000 applications
on the Play Store that
are using ExoPlayer.
And the team is
always really excited
to see the kind
of great products
that you're all building
using ExoPlayer.
Since last year's
talk, we've been
working hard on both
stability and performance
improvements behind the scenes,
but also on some brand-new
features.
And in doing that,
ExoPlayer is gradually
evolving into quite a
fully-featured solution
for media playback.
So here's some of the
highlights of the features
that we've added
over the past year.
There's much too much to
go into detail on here,
but I would encourage you
to check out the release
notes and the root directory
of our GitHub project,
where you can find full details
of all of the changes included
in each new release
of the player.
In today's talk,
we're just going
to cover a few highlights,
including support
for downloading
media as I mentioned,
and also support for
player notifications.
OK, I think that's
enough on the slides.
Let's get on with
some live coding,
and for each of these two apps,
our video app and audio app,
our starting point will
be a mostly empty project,
because we want to show you as
much of the interesting code as
possible.
But we're going to provide a
link to a branch on our GitHub
project where you can check
out the code afterwards
if you want to look at
things in a bit more detail.
OK, Marc, are you ready
to do some furious typing?
MARC BACHINGER: Yes, I am.
ANDREW LEWIS: Great.
OK, if you could switch
to the laptop, please.
Our starting point is a mostly
empty project, as I mentioned,
and we're going to make
a video player app where
we start playing the stream
as soon as the app comes
into the foreground,
and then we stop
playing the stream when
we go into the background.
And to do that,
the first step is
going to be to add a dependency
on the ExoPlayer core library,
and this provides the main
interface to the player
that you can use to control
playback from within code.
As you can see, Marc's
added a dependency
on the core library
with a version 2.8.0,
which is the new release
that we have done this week.
He's also added a dependency
on the optional UI module.
This provides some customizable
high-level UI components
which you can put into your
applications for things
like showing a video
player interview-- that's
Player View, which we're
going to use today.
And it also provides
Playback Control View
and some other components,
and these are all
very customizable,
so you can change
which icons you are using,
you can customize the layouts,
and so on.
So you can see that Marc has
added a Player View, which
is going to fill the activity.
And he's given it an
identifier, player_view,
so we'll be able to
access it from code.
Now, if we switch over
to our main activity,
we can see in our
onCreate methods,
we can get access to that
view using Find View by ID.
And once we got
access to that view,
then the next step
we're going to take
is to actually
initialize the player.
OK, so once we've got our
Player View in the fields,
let's override the
OnStart method.
And in OnStart, we're going
to initialize the player.
To initialize the
player, we're going
to use a static method on
the ExoPlayer factory called
NewSimpleInstance.
This is going to give us a
SimpleExoPlayer instance.
Now it might sound like
SimpleExoPlayer is only
for really basic stuff, but
actually SimpleExoPlayer
is our recommended way of
integrating at the moment
because it provides-- it
does lots of things for you.
For example, handling the
life cycle of the surface
holder for video output.
You can see also
that were parsing
in as well as a context, a
TrackSelector implementation.
In this example, we are going
to use a default TrackSelector,
but this is an example
of a parse in which
is very common in
ExoPlayer's API
where you parse in a
dependency of a component.
In this case, we're parsing
in a default TrackSelector,
but you could parse in your own
TrackSelector implementation
if you wanted to have
much more control over how
track selection is working.
So Marc's already going ahead
and he's bound the player
to the player view so that
the player's output is
going to appear in
that particular view.
OK, so the next step
is to tell ExoPlayer
what we want it to play.
And for that, there
are really two parts.
The first one is to provide
a factory for DataSources.
DataSources tell ExoPlayer
how to load data, for example,
using a particular HTTP
stack or loading files
from the local device.
In this example, we're using
a default DataSource which
is suitable for many use cases.
It provides loading
for HTTP URLs, follows
from the local disk assets and
resources bundled into your ADK
and so on.
But if you wanted
to, for example,
use the chromium
network stack here,
then you could use a
Cronet DataSourceFactory.
OK, so that's the first part of
telling ExoPlayer what to load.
The next part is
specifying a MediaSource.
Your choice of
MediaSource is going
to depend on the type of
media you're trying to play.
In this example, we're
going to be playing an MP4,
so we're going to use an
ExtractorMediaSource which
supports formats like MP4,
MP3, Matroska, and so on.
If you wanted to play Dash
or HLS or smooth streaming
streams, then you would use
the corresponding MediaSources
for those different formats.
And you can see that
Marc's parsing in the URI
to our MP4 when he's
creating the MediaSource.
Once we've got our
MediaSource, now we
just need to prepare the
player to start buffering data,
so we'll parse that
to the prepare method.
That we're going to
call SetPlayWhenReady
to tell the player that
as soon as it transitions
from the buffering state
to the ready state,
then playback should
begin automatically.
Having done that,
all that remains
is to clean up when the activity
goes into the background,
so we'll overwrite
onStop, and in that, we're
going to clear the player
reference on the Player View,
and then we're going
to release the player.
And this is kind of the
minimal code you need just
to play a video stream.
Let's go ahead and deploy
that to the device now.
And if we could switch
to the phone, please.
Hopefully you haven't
missed out anything.
So when the application's
been installed on the device,
you should see the video
starts to play automatically,
[VIDEO PLAYING]
And you can see that if
you tap on the video,
you get some simple
playback controls--
pretty much what you'd expect
from a video player app,
so you can pause and resume,
you can seek around, and so on.
Let's now switch back
to the laptop, please.
So let's imagine we have
launched our video app.
If we could switch to
the laptop, please.
We've launched our
video app, and now we'd
like to think about how
we're going to monetize
our content by showing ads.
This is extremely easy
to do with ExoPlayer.
We've recently added
an IMA extension,
which makes this very easy.
So ExoPlayer
extensions are wrappers
around external
functionality that
make it very easy to
use with ExoPlayer.
In this case, the IMA
extension is a wrapper
around the interactive media
ads SDK, which provides support
for loading XML ad
texts in VAST and VMAP
formats, which is a standard
format for information
about ads.
So we're going to be
using that to load ads,
and then we're
going to insert it
within the content
in our player.
So Marc's going to create
a ads loader, which is a--
we're going to use an
IMA ads loader, which
is the object that's provided
by the IMA extension.
This is going to take the
context and an ad tag URI,
which is the URI of an
XML document specifying
what ads to play
where in the content.
So we're going to create
the ads later in onCreate,
and then we're going to
release it in onDestroy.
The reason we're using
onCreate and onDestroy
is that that ads loader contains
information about which ads
have already been
played, so we want
to make sure that if the
app goes into the background
and comes back into
the foreground,
we don't show the same
ads multiple times.
As I mentioned before,
media sources are
how we tell ExoPlayer what to
play, and in order to play ads,
we use the predictably
named AdsMediaSource.
So we're going to create
an AdsMediaSource.
We'll parse in the
contentMediaSource
that we want to play.
We'll parse in a
DataSourceFactory
which is going to be used to
load data for playing the ads.
We'll parse in the Ads
Loader, and finally we'll
parse in a View Group
that's on top of the player,
and that's going to be
used to show any user
interface associated with
ads, like for example,
the Skip button.
And building an
AdsMediaSource out
of a contentMediaSource
like this
is an example of
MediaSource composition,
and this is something that
you can do with ExoPlayer.
We'll see some
more examples of it
later when we look at playlists.
OK, so we prepare the player
with the AdsMediaSource,
and then we should
be good to go.
So you can see, we--
hopefully this will work.
If we can switch to the phone?
We were able to add
support for playing ads
with maybe 10 or
so lines of code,
and actually this way of
integrating the IMA SDK
gives a really good
user experience,
because ExoPlayer knows
about which ads are coming up
in the future, and
that means that it's
going to be able to buffer
the content in advance.
It can buffer the ads
in advance to give you
seamless transitions
between ads and content.
So as you saw, we had a
pre-roll ad at the beginning,
and now the time bar has
little yellow markers,
which are showing us
the positions of ads
within the content.
And ExoPlayer is
taking care of all
of the difficulty
of loading the ads
and buffering everything
behind the scenes for us.
OK, so that's ad play
back, and now over to Marc
to talk a bit about audio.
MARC BACHINGER: Yeah.
Thank you, Andrew.
So far, we focused
on video only,
so let's switch to
another application
and look a little bit
into audio playback.
Audio playback is a little
bit more challenging
because we want
to enable the user
to put our application
into the background
and use another application,
and audio should still
keep playing in the background.
For this, we are going to use a
so-called "foreground service."
It's called a foreground
service because we
need to attach a
notification to this service,
and this notification
is in the foreground.
It's visible to the
user, so the user
is always aware we are doing
some work in the background.
Since [INAUDIBLE] such
a foreground service
is a mandatory requirement.
If we don't put our service
into the foreground,
the system will kill our service
and the application crashes.
So let's have a
look at the starting
point of our foreground
service, and let's switch back
to the laptop, please.
Yes, we see here we have
this AudioPlayerService which
extends from the service,
because we have already
overwritten the
onCreate method where
we put the code from
our video sample,
where we initialize and prepare
the player with a single media
item.
In onDestroy, we'll
release our resources.
And finally in onStart
command, we return StartSticky,
so the service is not
immediately destroyed
and we can explicitly terminate
our service when we are ready--
when we are finished
with audio playback.
The service also already
reaches in the manifest.
We have this simple
service element
which just points to our
AudioPlayerService clause.
And finally, we need to have
a way to start our service.
We do this in the
main activity--
in the onCreate method
of the main activity.
Here we create an
intent pointing
to our AudioPlayerService,
and then we
use a static method of the
ExoPlayer library, which
starts the service in foreground
according to the API level.
So now let's go back into
the AudioPlayerService
again, and let's
change this code
a little bit of where we
initialize our player,
because for audio, we
don't want to only support
playing a single media item.
We want to support playlists so
the user can move to the next
or to the previous item, or can
just let the player display one
item after the other.
With ExoPlayer, we are using
a concatenatingMediaSource
to implement playlists.
This concatenatingMediaSource
just joins together
a number of MediaSources
and place them gaplessly
and without
rebuffering in between,
so we achieve a pretty nice user
experience for audio playback.
The concatenatingMediaSource
also
allows us to dynamically
change the playlists,
so we can add and
remove MediaSources
while the player is
playing, or we can even
move the currently playing
item in our playlist
while the player is playing.
That's pretty neat.
So Andrew already started to
iterate over our samples area,
and for each sample,
we get a URI.
We again are going to create
an extractorMediaSource,
but then we add this
extractorMediaSource
to our concatenatingMediaSource.
In the end, we
prepare our player
with this
concatenatingMediaSource
and we are already done.
We are now supporting playlists
with gapless play, gapless
reach, play gaplessly,
and without rebuffering.
So-- but now let's have
a look at our service
again and make it a
proper foreground service.
We've already said we need
to attach a notification
to our foreground
service, and for this, we
are going to use the Player
Notification Service Manager.
The Player Notification
Manager will not only
create the notification, but
it will keep it nicely in sync
with the state of the
player, so each time
the player stage
changed, the Manager
will update an application and
post it to our drawer again.
We use a static method to
create this Player Notification
Manager, and we need to
parse a couple of arguments
[INAUDIBLE].
First, we need to
parse the context.
Then, we need to
parse the channel
ID, which identifies
our channel to which
we post our notification.
The next parameter is
a string identifier,
which gives us a localized
name for our channel.
This is the name which shows
up in the settings dialog
where our user maybe want to
mute our notification channel.
And then next parameter
is a notification ID
to identify our
notification, and finally, we
need to parse a so-called
Media Description Adapter.
The Manager will use our
adapter to get information
about the currently
playing item,
so each time the
notification is rebuilt,
the adapter is called
to get this information.
So we see that for each
of those callbacks,
the player instance is
parsed to the method,
so we can use this player to
get the current window index.
The current window
index give us the index
to pick our sample out of
our samples area, which
is kind of the playlists.
We return the title to
get the content title,
then we have a pretty
similar method where we just
return the description,
which is a longer text which
is displayed in the
context notification.
And finally, we also
provide a bitmap
to make our notification
a little bit nicer.
We just use a convenient
method for our samples
to get such a bitmap
for each of our samples.
Finally, we also need to
provide a pending intent.
This pending intent
is fired when
the user taps on
the notification,
and we want to get the user
back to our application
in our example to
the main activity.
So we create an intent
pointing to our main activity,
and then we wrap this
intent into a pending intent
which we are using
with the static method
get activities on
the pending intent.
Here again, a
couple of arguments.
The context-- that's
the first argument.
Then a request code,
which is 0 in our case.
We are not going to
use it in our sample.
Then the intent pointing to
our main activity, and finally,
a flag to tell the system
to update any pending
intent already in the queue.
So now we have this Player
Notification Manager.
We now also need to [INAUDIBLE]
a notification listener.
This listener makes our
service aware of the life
cycle of our notification.
It has two methods, so we
register this notification
[INAUDIBLE] listener,
which is an anonymous class
in this case.
The first method or
notification started
is called when the notification
is initially created.
Here, we now parse those
two arguments to the start
foreground service,
and this is now
the moment where our
service is officially
at foreground service.
We are now safe.
The system is not going to
kill our service anymore.
The next method
then is called when
the notification is canceled.
Here it just stops
self our service
because we want to
terminate the service.
Finally, we also
need to [INAUDIBLE]
that the player resets the
player with the set player
method on the
Notification Manager,
so the Notification Manager
can sync the player state
to the notification.
So that's about it.
We also need to clean up
in the onDestroy method.
Here we just null the
set-- the player instance
again so we don't leak
a player reference when
the service is being destroyed.
So now please change
back to the phone,
and if we've done
everything right,
we should now be able to
hear the playlist playing
in our service.
The application comes up.
We see the notification
in the drawer with the--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It's playing.
Then let's have a look at the
notification in the drawer.
We see here the information
which comes from our adapter.
We can use the playback
controls to control playback.
We can pause or start again.
We can skip to the
next item, and if we
tap on the notification, it
gets us back to the application.
So fine.
So as the next step,
when we have seen now
that this notification
contains information
about the current item
and about the state,
and it lets the user
control the media playback.
What if we want to
expose this functionality
to external application?
Let's go to the [INAUDIBLE]
Can we go back to the slides,
please?
Thank you.
Google Assistant, for
example, may want to--
yeah, here we are.
Here we go.
Google Assistant,
for example, wants
to allow the user to use voice
commands to control media
playback.
Android Auto or Wear OS
lets the user remote control
a media application
and browse in a media
catalog of our application.
The Android framework
has a solution for this,
because we essentially need
to provide three things
to let external application
participate in media playback.
First, we need to expose
the playback state.
This is the things
like the player state
itself, the current media item,
or the playlist with which
we prepared our player.
Second, we need to be able
to retrieve playback commands
from external application so
we can execute those commands
on our player instance.
And third, we need
to provide ways
to browse in our media catalog.
The Android framework
provides a solution for this.
It provides the MediaSession
and the MediaBrowserService.
We are not going into the detail
of the MediaBrowserService,
because we don't
have time for this,
but we look at the
MediaSession, which
allows us to expose
the playback state
and retrieve playback commands.
In our code sample,
we are going to use
the MediaSessionConnector,
which is
part of the MediaSession
extension of the ExoPlayer
library.
This MediaSessionConnector
synchronizes the player state
with the state of
the MediaSession
and retrieves commands
from the MediaSession.
So let's change again
back to the laptop,
please, so we can see how
we can do this in code.
We are again the onCreate method
of our AudioPlayerService,
and we are now going to create
an instance of a MediaSession
compart.
We assign it to a field, we
just call MediaSession Compart
Constructor with a
context and an identifier
which is just the string.
Then we immediately set
our MediaSession to active
by parsing through to
the SetActiveMethod.
Now as a first step, we want
to make the Player Notification
Manager aware of our session,
and we parse the token
to the Player
Notification Manager
so we can enhance the
media style notification
and provide an artwork for
our lock screen of our device.
But now we are going to create
such a MediaSessionConnector.
We call the Constructor and
we just parse the MediaSession
to the Connector so it
has access to the session.
We said we want to
synchronize our playlist
with the queue of
the MediaSession
so external application
know what items
we are having in our playlists.
For this, we are going to
use a TimelineQueueNavigator.
The Timeline is the internal
representation of the playlist
after the player
has been prepared,
so there are as many
windows in our Timeline
as we have items
in our playlists.
So with this, we can use
the window index, which
is the parameter which is parsed
to our method we are going
to override to create to
get the samples again out
of our samples area,
and we then are
going to create a
MediaDescription for such
a sample.
Let's have a look in this
getMediaDescription method
to see that there is not
much magic behind it.
We see we are just using
a MediaDescription compart
builder, and then we
populate this data
with the data from our
samples, and then we
build such a MediaDescription
compart, which
we return to our connector.
So now we have already
this MediaSessionConnector.
As a next step, again, we
need to parse the player
to the connector so
we can sync the player
with the MediaSession.
Here we again use
the SetPlayerMethod.
The first parameter
is the player itself.
The second parameter
is a playback prepare.
We are not going to
use it because we
don't want to allow external
application to initiate
playback in our sample.
So that's kind of it.
Again, in onDestroy,
we need to clean up.
First we just release
the MediaSession,
and the second step, we
again set the player instance
to null, this time
in the connector
to avoid leaking an
instance of the player.
So now that's kind of it.
If everything is
correct, we should
be able to deploy the
application again.
Please switch to
the phone again,
and Andrew should now be able
to use Google Assistant to skip
to the next item.
Let's see if this works.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDREW LEWIS: Play next track.
[NEW SONG PLAYING]
MARC BACHINGER: Oi, fine.
Well done.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
And now over to Andrew again
for downloading and offline
functionality.
ANDREW LEWIS: Thank you, Marc.
And if we could switch
back to the slides, please?
OK.
So another feature of
media apps that I'm
sure you're all familiar with
is support for downloading
media for offline playback.
This is really
important if your users
are going to be in
a situation where
they have no connectivity or
intermittent connectivity.
This has been a much-requested
feature for a while now,
and we're really
pleased that we've
been able to launch this in
our 2.8.0 release this week.
In ExoPlayer, our
support for downloading
is built on top of our
support for caching,
so I'm going to say a
little bit about how
caching fits into the
picture of the player set up,
and then we'll look
at how downloading
builds on top of that.
So this diagram is intended
to show you that data
flow when playing one MP3 file.
We have a song which is
in the cloud somewhere,
we have a data source which
is requesting that over HTTP--
that's loading the data--
and then we had a
MediaSource that
was getting the
information from there
and providing it to the player.
Let's see how caching
fits into this.
Well, it's quite simple.
We just add a CacheDataSource.
That sits in between
the DataSource
we're using for loading from
the network and the MediaSource
that's providing
data to the player.
And it's going to be responsible
for dealing with a cache
instance.
In this case, we're
using a simple cache
which is provided by
ExoPlayer's core library.
The way this works
is as follows.
When the MediaSource
requests some data,
it's going to ask the
CacheDataSource to provide
that information.
The CacheDataSource is
going to look in the cache.
If it is present there,
then that's great.
We can get the data
from local storage.
That goes to the
MediaSource, and we never
had to go to the network.
On the other hand, if the data
is not present in the cache,
so we've got a cache miss,
than the CacheDataSource needs
to go to the DataSource
that's being used
to load from the
network, and it's
going to request
the data from there,
and then it's going to store it
in the cache when it arrives.
And in this way,
the cache gradually
gets populated with the data
that's loaded during playback.
You can see also
on this diagram,
we've got a CacheEvictor.
This component is
responsible for making sure
that our cache doesn't
grow indefinitely
as we play more and more
different media items.
OK, now let's move on to
think about downloading.
So downloading is a
separate operation
which you might want to
perform in the background,
so it might need a service.
And this downloading operation--
what's going on internally
is it's going to read
through the entire stream,
and as it does that, it'll
be populating the same cache
instance that you're
using for playback.
And as you can probably guess,
when you do this operation,
if you've populated the
cache with all of the data,
then when it comes to
playback, your player
is going to be able
to get everything
from the cache from
the CacheDataSource.
There's never a need to go
to the network in this case.
One very important
thing to note is
that we've got a
[INAUDIBLE] CacheEvictor,
so this is an implementation
of CacheEvictor
which does nothing.
It's never going to evict
data from the cache.
The reason we have
that is that we
don't want to have a situation
whereby we're downloading
the stream, and then
when we've downloaded up
to a certain amount of data,
we start getting rid of data
at the beginning of the
stream, because that would
be very annoying for users.
So that's the theory.
Let's see how this
works in practice.
If we could switch back
to the laptop, please.
So we're going to do
this in three steps.
The first step is we're
going to add support
for caching to our player.
Then we're going to implement
an audio download service which
is going to actually
run the download
operation in the background.
Then finally, we're going to
add a very minimal piece of UI
to our activity in
order to let us trigger
the downloads to take place.
So we'll go ahead and create
a CacheDataSourceFactory,
and as we saw on
the slide, this is
going to sit between
our DataSourceFactory
for loading from the network
and the MediaSource, which
is actually going to be
extracting the media.
So you can see we're
using a utility
method to get our cache.
Let's jump into that and
see what's going on there.
So as I mentioned, we're sharing
the same cache for playback
and downloading, and
that means it's important
that we just have a singleton
for our whole process.
Inside getCache,
what we're doing is
we check if we've
got one already.
If we don't have
one, we're going
to create a file which is
pointing to a directory
where we're going to
store the downloads.
Then we're going to instantiate
a simple cache, parsing
in that directory, and also a
[INAUDIBLE] CacheEvictor, which
is very important, because we
don't want to be removing data
from the cache.
So that's how we
make a simple cache.
We also need to provide
the CacheDataSourceFactory
with the upstream
DataSourceFactory
for loading data
from the network.
OK, and that's what
we need to instantiate
a CacheDataSourceFactory.
Let's introduce a local
variable for that,
and then we're going to use that
CacheDataSourceFactory in place
of the DataSourceFactory
we were using before
for loading from the network.
So hopefully that makes
sense for adding support
for caching to our player.
Now we're going to
move on and we're
going to add an audio
DownloadService, which
is actually going to run
the downloading operation.
So we provide a super plus
called DownloadService
for your download
services that you'll
be putting in your
application, so we'll
be inheriting from that here.
So there's a few steps
we need to do now.
The most important one--
important not to
forget is to add
a declaration for the
service to your manifest.
So we're going to add our
audio DownloadService here.
Now we can switch
back, and we have
to implement a constructor
and three methods.
So let's start doing that.
We'll create a constructor
with no arguments,
but then we're going to
call the super constructor
and parse in some information
about the download
notifications.
So we'll need a
notification ID which
must be different
from the notification
ID we used for audio playback.
We'll also parse in
an interval at which
to update with the
notification, and we'll just
use the default here.
We'll parse in a channel ID
for our download notification
channel, and
finally, we also need
to provide a string
resource which
describes the
notification channel,
and that works just
the same as the one
we did for audio playback that
had the notification channel as
well.
Now we need to
override some methods,
so let's have a look at those.
The first one is we need to
provide a Download Manager,
and we have a utility
method for this which we'll
have a look at in a second.
That's just taking a context.
Let's jump in there.
So again, we're using
a singleton instance
of a Download Manager
for our whole process.
This is also creating
a file, because it
needs to persist some
information about downloads
that are in progress.
And then we're instantiating
a Download Manager,
parsing in the same
cache instance as the one
that we're using for the
cache during playback.
You can see also there is a
DataSourceFactory for loading
data to populate
the cache, and we've
also got a de-serializer for
progressive download actions,
because we're downloading
progressive media.
For getScheduler, for the
purposes of our simple demo
app, we're just going to
leave this returning null,
but in a real
application, you would
want to provide some
kind of JobScheduler
so that the system can start
your download service when
your process isn't running,
in order to resume downloads.
You can have a look at our full
demo app for an example of how
to do that.
Finally, we're going to provide
a progress notification,
and we've got our handy utility
method to build one here.
This is going to
take a context--
an icon which is
going to be shown
in the notification associated
with the download that's
in progress--
and we'll just use our
playback icon for that.
Then we'd provide
the download channel
ID, which is the same
one that we used earlier.
This one is actually a
string, not a resource.
One parameter [INAUDIBLE].
OK, so we get our
download channel ID.
We actually need an intent next,
which we'll just parse null
for, then we've got a bit mixed
up with the parameters here.
So if you remove
download channel name--
MARC BACHINGER: Oh.
ANDREW LEWIS: Easily done.
There's lots of parameters.
Then the message is null,
content intent is null,
the message is
null, and we'll just
parse our task states,
which has information
about the downloads
that are in progress--
what their status is.
Whew.
That's a lot of parameters.
OK, so that looks pretty good.
That's implementing
our download service.
The final step, I
promise, is just
providing a way to trigger these
downloads from our activity.
So as you can see, we've
got an empty list view here.
We're going to replace that
with a list of samples,
so we've just got three
items and a playlist.
When the user taps
one of those, we're
going to trigger the
download to start, and to do
that, we'll be creating a
progressive download action.
If you are downloading a
different type of content
like a Dash stream,
than you would not
use progressive download action.
You'd use the corresponding
download action
for the type of stream
you're downloading.
That's going to take a URI.
It's going to take a flag to
say whether we're [INAUDIBLE]
or not.
We want to add it to the
cache, so we'll parse in false.
We don't want to
associate any custom data,
so we'll parse null for the
data and the custom cache key.
Once we've created our
progressive download action,
all that remains is to call a
method on the download service.
There's a static method to start
the service with that action,
and that takes a context,
which is main activity
dot this, not the item
click-- listener this.
It takes the class
of the download
service, which is audio
download service dot class.
It takes the download action
which we've just created--
progressive download
action-- and finally, we
can parse false for foreground
because our activity is already
in the foreground.
That's quite a few
bits to remember there,
but hopefully we've
got everything.
Let's give that a try
and see if it works.
Now, we had plans to show you
putting the device into flight
mode and playing back
the downloaded content,
but unfortunately we're having
to use Cast to play the stream,
so we won't actually be
able to show you the putting
the device in flight mode.
You'll need to use
your imagination.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
As you can see when
we type the items,
you get a little play icon which
is our download notification,
and that's going to progress
as the download progresses,
and that's populating the
cache in the background.
OK, so that's pretty
much it for downloading.
I'm now going to hand
back over to Marc
to say a few words about Cast.
MARC BACHINGER: Yeah.
Thank you, Andrew.
So there is a last
important integration
we did not cover in code, and
we will not cover in code.
It's the integration
with Google Cast.
Google Cast is almost
expected by our users
to be supported by media apps.
We've recently added
a Cast extension,
which makes integration
with Cast for ExoPlayer
application pretty easier.
Let's switch to the
slides again, please.
Thank you.
The Cast extension
takes advantage
of the player interface
of the ExoPlayer library.
All the UI components
and other components
like the
PlayerNotification manager,
the MediaSession Connector
which we've seen in action,
take advantage of
this player interface,
and only rely on this
player interface.
The most prominent
implementation
of this player interface
is the SimpleExoPlayer.
Almost all ExoPlayer
applications
use the SimpleExoPlayer a
player for local playback.
The Cast extension now
adds another implementation
of this player interface
which is the CastPlayer.
The CastPlayer wraps the remote
media client of the Cast SDK
so it gets pretty easy to
swap local playback down
with the SimpleExoPlayer
with remote playback
of the CastPlayer.
So because all those components
of the ExoPlayer library
and hopefully also
your application only
rely on the player
interface, you
can exchange this local
playback with remote playback
quite easily.
You can also have a look at
the Cast demo application which
we add to our GitHub
repository, and we have also
a blog post on Medium
which shows you
how to set up the Cast
parts for your application.
ANDREW LEWIS: OK, great.
Thank you, Marc.
So all that remains really
is to provide you with a link
to the branch which has the
code that we've written today,
or at least it will be
very similar to the code we
have written today.
Please go and check
that out and try it out.
You will actually be able to
try the download functionality
by putting your device into
flight mode and making sure
that it plays it back,
which we can't do now.
So please check that out.
We have an office hours
session today at 3:30.
Please come along if
you've got questions.
Lots of members of the
team will be there,
and we'd be delighted
to meet you and find out
about what you're
doing with ExoPlayer
and how we can
help you with that.
This is a link to
our GitHub project.
If you haven't seen that before,
we have a developer guide which
takes you through the
process of getting
started with ExoPlayer at
a slightly slower pace,
and it helps to explain
some of the background.
And finally, as Marc
alluded to, we also
have a blog on Medium where
members of the ExoPlayer team
are writing blog posts
about new functionality
that we're working on.
So please do check
that out and subscribe.
And with that,
thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]